hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review i thought i was done with
the psa
power plant analysis i think i did 23
tests uh two videos and thousands of uh
forum posts
but uh that was not meant to be um a
couple days ago or yesterday ps audio
released a video and uh with their
measurements of of the unit
and a lot of people have asked me for my
feedback and i try to explain text but
it's a lot better to do it in a video
where i can speak freely
and then also post my video releases um
we had a bunch of really good technical
discussions and and figured out more
about the
uh technical uh uh operation of the
device beyond what the company is
advertised and shown so i thought uh i'd
go through both of those uh with you
today because they actually go hand in
hand
and i'm doing in a powerpoint apologize
for that i couldn't figure out an easier
way to do it
so let me summarize first what we
tested and the the outcomes that we had
um
on the positive front the ps audio p12
does generate cleaner
mains
ac signal it has lower distortion has a
little bit more noise but let's forgive
that it has lower distortion
significantly so
but as an ac generator regenerator is
not a great device um
my lab being k9801 which is less than
half the price although at lower power
generates far far cleaner power
so
you know if one decides that you need a
power regenerator uh you know in a
competitive situation it does it does
not do well at all
um
it does do regulation which means if
your voltage sags below 120 volts in us
i measured all the way down to 90 95
volts it will step it up to 120 and if
you go above 120 it will pull it back
down so it does provide
regulation in both
directions
both of these are given they're not
disputed and as you'll see later on bulk
of what ps audio tries to do in their
video
is to prove these points again which
didn't make sense
uh the key was that despite the cleanup
that he did on on ac mains
i couldn't
measure any improvement electrical
improvement on the output of either
searching power supply or a linear power
supply the most common kinds of of
power supplies you have in your audio
devices and there's
you know real engineering reasoning
behind that and that is because the
power supplies have uh
they convert things to dc by uh
filtering the ac and
and they also have regulators and those
regulators guarantee a voltage that's
needed inside the device 3.3 volts 5
volt 12 volts whatever the case may be
and
the regulations already there and that's
why we don't need the upstream
regulation in ac it's assumed the ac
varies and because of that we have
regulation inside the device
which means by definition every engineer
that designs audio equipment
knows that ac varies and that's one of
the design criteria um on this and
it's also assumed that the ac is not
clean
so there's filtering in there to produce
the performance that the device requires
so that was sort of we've we sort of
characterized ac and said yes it does
something on the ac but then we
characterize the power supply which is
the next stage after ac input and showed
that it does not care and nothing
changes in its output and naturally when
we then tested what's a downstream of a
power supply which is your audio
equipment it also showed no improvement
at all and
there were two types of devices that i
tested one was a headphone amplifier one
was a power amp with a switching power
supply
uh and i'll get in a second to uh one
without the switching power supply both
of those showed identical performance
with or without uh ps audio uh p12 so
we've gone through a chain of three
stages
in the pipeline
and characterize the device in the first
stage ac there was improvement but we
don't listen to ac we don't use ac we
step it down to dc and then i showed
that it it makes no difference
now there was a a a an inverted uh issue
in that we actually found a problem with
using the p12 in that when i tested the
linear amplifier uh on its high current
output which we call hc output the
outlets in the back performance actually
went down rather than going up less
wattage was produced by this amplifier
which is exact opposite a company
specifies a
output impedance of 0.008 which is
essentially zero but my uh impedance
measurement meter showed more than three
ohms it can't measure more than three
ohms so it could have been a lot more
than three ohms and um
that would explain why we were
getting less wattage because there was a
voltage drop across that outlet and we
were getting less power not more so this
is a case where the the power plant p12
was actually doing damage to our system
in degrading his performance objectively
no doubt about it you got less power i
think about seven and a half percent
less power and why would you spend six
thousand dollars on device that gives
you less power
so
um
unfortunately you can use the non-high
current outputs outlets and that didn't
degrade the performance you know produce
a little bit less wattage but we can
forgive that
but it also didn't improve whatsoever
not a single extra watt was produced
and distortion and noise nothing was
changed so the notion that you need to
clean up the ac was proven again in this
third device um that it also didn't care
and didn't need a power plant
company's response in forums and just
wishy-washy stuff from paul mcgowan uh
was that oh there is a current limited
in a high current output but we bypass
it after a few seconds or some to that
effect well that didn't happen there was
no bypassing my testing takes a long
time and frankly you can't do that it
just makes no sense to be a bypassing in
there and indeed there isn't
so that was the summary of you know two
or three weeks of my testing extensively
reviewed and argued by many people
internally to audio sounds review and
externally this is solid
as as it can be and uh so let's see what
uh ps audio did
i didn't want to play their content
you're welcome to go and
play the response um
let me explain what they measured uh on
this so they first measured the power
coming out of this long power strip
the designer has on his bench
and as you can imagine that probably is
not the best you know way to distribute
power to an audio system so
they first measured that and they got
122 volts output
on this and then he's built a dummy load
basically big resistors cooled with a
fan
and when you flip these switches it puts
a heavy load on on the mains i think was
700 watts or 900 watts i forget which
and when it did that the voltage dropped
minuscule amount 122 down to 118.
no audio device cares whatsoever that
your ac main
drop from 122 to 118 to 3 volts
nothing the internal voltage in a in an
audio device is you know 10 20 volts 30
volts it's it's not you know 122 volts
and that's step down
uh to those low voltages and then
regulations provided so
it's just right away it's a bad idea to
show this now if that voltage had gone
from 122 to 85 you say okay oh wow
there's a voltage drop and this is
despite putting basically hair dryer
load on this thing constant load on it
not a momentary load as you play music
where those impulses come and they can
be served by the capacitor reservoir in
the in your audio device they put a
constant resistor load in here just
cooking in their you know basically 700
watt heater or 900 watt heater and all
they could show was two or three volts
then they said well lookie uh when i uh
go through uh the uh p12 it's back up to
120 volts well yeah i already measured
that it regulates from 90 to 135 volts i
think with the range of measured it
regulates but again we don't need
regulation of ac
because 99.9 percent of the world
of audio files as audio equipment that
runs perfectly on unregulated ac you
know regulator ac is not a requirement
no manual for any audio device ever come
out and says hey for the best
performance you better feed it regulated
ac
they all have one regulator but anyway
so it regulated but so what that's not
the point of how we were making and
already you know said it regulates
then they try to measure the impedance
of the wall outlet it's not really wall
outlets this power strip over here
and really a diy type of measurement
setup i expected them to have a line
analyzer and a professional equipment
that measures current voltage
and instead we have a
portable dmm for voltage measurement
which is fine but for current
measurement he uses a current probe a
current probe is a non-invasive
probe transformer or usually a single or
more than one loop that you put around
the wire and using its magnetic
induction you can deduce how much
current is going in there this is only
used sort of more or less for technician
work or quick analysis i can walk up to
a meter in your home and just put the
probe on on one of the cables and say
whoa it's pulling this much car or in
your car i can go and put that in there
that requires a dc uh current
measurement which is a different animal
but anyway this has gone non-invasive
and you get convenience in that you
don't have to touch break the wire but
you also don't get very high accuracy
with these things indeed if you move and
wiggle these probes uh the amount the
current that they show changes because
the induction is is not perfect
um the right way to do that is you cut
the wire and you put an ammeter in
between them and you measure now he's
made his own dummy load i would have
then put a you know
pass-through uh
amp meter through this and measure ac
amps and not try to use this this dewey
key over here now i i have many current
probes as well don't get me wrong there
very useful where you could just walk up
and measure current
but it's just if you're going to try to
show what he's going to do in a second
which is do a division of voltage the
current and get the impedance
you know you want to have that current
be accurate when you try to compute
numbers this small .054
anyway
this also i showed in my measurements i
showed that my ac mains
i think was like .3 or something and
when i used p12 high low current
outlets it did go down some didn't go
down this much but it goes down some
and
it was given but here's the kick here
this specification for
for p12 says that the
impedance with no qualification
is 0.008
right in front of us they're measuring
and getting 0.054
well that's one decimal place off of
this thing it's about eight times worse
than
what the spec is and then when that
happens you know paul sort of catches
that he says oh yeah when we measure it
we we don't use all of this stuff we go
right inside the thing and measure it oh
really
how do i tap into the connect my
amplifier right inside this box i have
to go through outlets i have to go
through power chords and therefore that
defeats the purpose of having such a
small impedance so as a practical matter
you would never ever see this impedance
uh facing your devices you see more like
what he's showing which is off by one
decimal place uh on this thing so
that
you know that alone just shows and by
the way i speculated that's with her to
win because you just i know i have
measured connections and you know i know
these outlets alone have more impedance
than this so what they said was just
silliness they should have been at least
an asterisk they measured internally or
computed i don't even know they measured
it internally uh clearly it's not what
you as a consumer are going to get it's
like saying 0 to 60 is three seconds for
your car but little asterisk says we
took all the seats out you know it's
just not you gotta say that you took out
all the seats in the car so anyway but
again at high level
it's fine you know we we said it does
that it has slightly lower impedance um
than what i measured and that was not a
dispute what the issue was was this high
current outlet where the impedance was
very high and if you look in here which
outlet is using these are all low
current outlets over here only the last
one next to this ac input is high
current so he's not using the high
current outlet despite paul knowing full
well their ceo that's in this video that
tons of debate was around what the high
current outlet did because that's what
you hook up to an amplifier
this impedance does not matter one iota
if you got a little dac in there it's
pulling 100 watts or 50 watts
the impedance there's no there's so
little current being pulled that the
impedance losses it's just minuscule
even if that there was no power supply
in your deck so to go and do all this
video production
when he perfectly knows the point of
debate
was this high current outlets right here
these two over here they go measure the
low current atlas where there was no
debate i said if you use the low current
outlets you do get low impedance didn't
generate more power and uh
on this thing but hey you know
that wasn't the dispute the dispute is
the manual says nothing about avoiding
high current outlets they are
regenerated and but they have high
impedance they have some kind of current
limiter with ntc or something else in
there and that current limit is just
destroying any story they have around
impedance because it actually produces
higher impedance here than this power
strip does in his lap so
it just boggles my mind that they
try to answer what we're doing or try to
show the capability of the device and
they don't show you why you know the one
port that's different than the rest they
don't tell you what it is
anyway
let's move on after they do that they
said whoa so that's you know we do the
regulation but
um
what we also do is that we clean up the
waveform okay
again that wasn't the dispute um you
know but i thought they would put in
proper analyzers around this thing and
show the measurements
no they go look at the front panel
displaying this this little low
resolution display so look look how much
how clean this waveform is that's coming
out of the device well there's not
enough pixels in here to see
what it is in here that is wrong number
one and so what you want to do is and
i'll show you in a second you do a
four-year transform and that shows you
all the distortion and noise spikes you
can't see noise in here in this little
display and
i showed that the meter in this thing is
three times inaccurate uh in some cases
so you know even this distortion meter
is no good why doesn't the designer have
a you know a line analyzer sitting up
here as a minimum
that shows you proper thc
uh on that or better yet use audio
precision setup i have which gives
extremely high performance analysis of
of the main signal
they don't have either one they're
relying on a dummy meter a little you
know low-cost freebie meter they got in
here it's not freebie custom money but
you know what i'm talking about this is
a consumer device not an instrument um
after a show that is inaccurate they go
ahead and keep saying look at looking
over here it's cleaning yes it is
cleaner that's not a problem the problem
is that the downstream devices don't
care and this is not the way to prove
that it is cleaner uh on this thing
so anyway um
let's go further
they have this multi-wave thing and i
turn it on and off and i didn't notice
any difference they say that what
multi-wave does it actually takes the
waveform and fattens it in other words
it flattens the top much earlier than
this that we kept saying that you want
to have the original peak restored
because it gets flattened because it
gets pounded on but now they added the
third harmonic which fattens this up you
could say it generates more energy in
there
but my ac waveform where i analyze it
already had the third harmonic in it so
they first removed the third harmonic by
20 db or whatever then they add it back
in again it's like wait a second is
distortion bad for ac or is it good for
the ac make up your mind you can't say
that i've got to remove distortion from
ac to make it good then you turn around
and says oh i've got this bonus feature
you turn it on and
it adds distortion to it and distorts
that pretty sine wave to be a you know
fattened sound wave
it makes no sense at all but yes it is
true that those harmonics carry a little
bit of power and uh when you take them
out with the p12 or any of their power
plants you're actually reducing
available energy to the power supply
inside your audio code
so
before we get into all the measurements
there's an introduction to this video
where paul says what he's been saying
for a while which is uh
this statement is quite nebulous i've
got the closed caption turned on but
that's what he's saying
he says creates a perfect
low distortion
ac signal
a perfect low distortion perfect means
no distortion if it's low distortion
then slow distortion is not perfect
perfect means
nothing wrong with it or at least
infinitesimally small
aberrations in there if you go to their
website they say
that's that too it says it takes
incoming ac power and regenerates a new
sine wave that's perfect
okay
and that
it doesn't have any of the problems such
as distorted waveforms
okay
so stay with me it says it that
eliminates noise it eliminates distorted
waveforms and it generates a perfect
wave and here's a perfect in here how
perfect is it well let's go back to my
measurements again
and this is where
discovery came from discussions in the
forum
this is my ac mains spectrum this is the
60 hertz which carries all the power and
then yes we have harmonics this is a
second harmonic throwdown running fourth
fifth and and it keeps going on and this
is a very wideband measurement going up
to a megahertz so lots of
stuff going on in there
and then let's look at what
uh i'll put up with ps audio p12 looks
like it also has the 60 hertz but
interestingly enough step back and look
at the shape of this waveform and look
at the shape of this waveform
they look identical don't they yes the
spikes have been lowered in amplitude
and i'll get to that in a second but
why on earth is this waveform so
identically close
to my raw ac
if you take ac and convert it to dc
then all of this is gone everything is
gone right it's dc it doesn't have the
ac 60 hertz doesn't have any of these
things right when you convert it to dc
and then you have a power amplifier
that's fed with 60 hertz
you then generate a new aec out of it it
would have distortion it would have
noise but it can't have the noise and
distortion it looks just like the input
that you fed it
how could this be
right it doesn't make sense that the
spectrum of a perfect sine wave
generated from conversion of ac to dc it
looks just like the ac again with little
bit less distortion but
every oddity is in here even this spike
over here just stepping down is in here
doesn't make sense right these two are
highly correlated uh waveforms
now let's look at how
it works when i have a proper
lab ac regenerator which is my bnk 9801
bk precision 9801 it's a lab generator
that i own costs 2500 and 300 watts and
when i when it does that
it truly generates a different spectrum
look at what it does
look at the noise floor in here looks
nothing like my noise floor look at how
much lower the noise floor is way down
here versus this look at the distortion
spikes the second harmonic is much
higher than mine so it's actually worse
in that regard but then all the other
harmonics are
actually a lot better
than that so that's why it's much
cleaner device and it has its own noise
and distortion like i said it's got all
these other spikes that mine didn't have
but overall it is much cleaner
notice that there's no correlation if
you step back this waveform looks
nothing like this and this is the way a
regenerator works again you're
converting ac to dc you get rid of all
the noise and distortion and you start
over again with a clean 60 hertz this is
what you get instead
we have this
what what is going on in here
well
let's look at some uh comparisons late
comparisons i have this psi your p300
which i think i bought 25 years ago 30
years ago
and it's only rated at 300 watts okay
and it weighs 30 pounds and it's a box
extremely deep it's 19 inches deep so
this is and it's all a heat sink i mean
it's a massive massive massive box and
it heats up that entire heatsink it's
just sitting there just
it's just a heat generator it's very
very very inefficient okay only 300
watts and he's 30 pounds say 19 inches
deep now look at the p12 is rated at
1250 watts so about four times more than
four times the power rating of this box
how much heavier is it
just seven pounds
37 pounds versus 30
doesn't make sense right
this p300
did convert ac to dc and back to ac and
because it's dealing with such high
voltages all the output stage runs so
inefficiently that it just
spit out a ton of heat that had to be
cooled with these massive heatsinks
so clearly there's some trickery going
on in here to get incredibly high
efficiency it out of the same conversion
you know is there some miracle in there
well
one technique
where we go get efficiency is by using
switching design although i don't know
it's non-trivial to apply to this domain
but the most likely explanation that
actually members were very good at
digging into older manuals and reading
between line is is that this line of
power plants from psatio is actually
partial regenerator
in other words you take some of the ac
pass it through the dirty water and mix
it with some bottled water and what you
get is a mixture of bottled water and
filtered water and the dirty water you
don't get all filtered all clean
new water
if you mix the two that explains why we
see similar
spectrum because all the noise and the
distortion as far as signature of the
noise and distortion in the ac mains
comes through yes there's less of those
distortions because you don't take the
full ac you take a
subset the of the ac signal and then you
power on more accurate um ac waveform on
top of that so the end result is that
you don't get a very clean ac but
because the power regenerator doesn't
have to
fully reproduce the entire waveform on
its own and deliver all the power on its
own
it winds up being a lot more efficient
because doing partial regeneration is
having to only produce that power and
incurs those losses not the full losses
now i challenged a company to come and
explain to me
why
this is not the case because there's
boarding in there for example where he's
trying to lock his internal sine wave
generator to the incoming ac why would
you need to lock the two waveforms
together if you're just trying to
generating fresh ac you don't need to
lock it to the incoming ac but you do if
you're trying to pile one on top of the
other and you want to line them up
now admittedly this is reading between
the line but like i said this evidence
here is quite damning in here as far as
you know companies saying get perfect
first of all this is not perfect i don't
know but whose definition is perfect if
this is perfect then this is perfect how
i see is because it has the same
signature it has the same distortions as
the same noise and everything and as
i've explained in the video it actually
has additional noise in here which kind
of makes sense you take the ac mains and
you put an amplifier on top that also
has noise and the two of them you know
climb up in noise so
not good you know if the company wants
to do another video have the design
explain to us how this works i'd love to
know and sadly they don't show you any
kind of measurements like this this is
the power of doing precise measurements
and knowing what you're doing and having
the right instrumentation
a voltmeter and ammeter isn't going to
give you this and looking at the front
panel of that display isn't going to
tell you this what they call perfect and
clean and look at how pretty that sign
wave is that sine wave has all this gun
color is still in it so it didn't give
you a perfect sound wave perfect sign
would be this spike here and nothing
else
all right
moving along
there is a
uh let me sort of step back and show you
proof point of why we don't need any of
this stuff
ac input again is considered variable we
step it down and then we post regulator
you don't believe me
here's ted smith designer of ps audio's
direct stream dac and tells you this
so i have multiple quality discrete
regulators
in series with a custom bootstrap
voltage reference for each
for each of these different sub-circuits
excuse me
he already has not only one regulator it
has multiple cascaded regulators is
built and this is quite common in high
performance devices they may have like a
switching power supply that spits out
wobbles or they may get a 12 volt thing
and then they step that down to
you know five volt what have you and
then you step it down again to 3.3 volts
oftentimes this is like multiple
filtering multiple re-regulation to get
rid of even the slightest amount of
ripple and also what he says also to
keep it from having one circuits the
volt power demands bleed into another
circuit's power demands so
this kind of thing is common go read the
specs from any high performance stack or
preamp and you'll see them in marketing
material they gush over ah they have
multiple regulators and there are four
regulators or six regulators
this is what a designer will do
internally because they want the device
to perform exceptionally well when
hooked up to any ac mains
which designer is sitting there
designing a preamp saying hmm
you know i'm going to have it work when
you have this device plugged into it but
if you don't all bets are off no you
know you assumed mains is always dirty
you assume mains is always variable
thankfully we don't need 120 volts
inside we need 12 volts 10 volts 5 volt
3.3 volts so we need so much less
voltage that we can have so much
headroom that we can just regulate that
and get superb performance
uh sometimes you just have to shake your
head so after paul posts this uh paul
mcgowan the ceo of the company uh
co-founder company posts this
uh on their forum the video
somebody comes out and quickly points
out to him said where's the high current
output uh measurements and why you're
not addressing all the things out of
your science review pointed out you
basically your testing is orthogonal you
know we you know i raised issues and you
didn't
well first part of it is that it says
this is my tests were silly and they
missed the point of the power plant
really
the point of a power plant
is to make your audio system run better
right
it i don't consume ac i don't stick the
ac on my tongue and or listen to it you
hook up a power plant to an audio system
there's nothing in there testing where
they took one of their amps or dax and
hooked it up to it and say look the
output got better
so
that's not i'm they're missing the point
of the power plant i'm not
and then begrudgingly so the tests
weren't incorrect well thank you very
much they were just misleading in a
negative way that doesn't help the
community
really which which community am i
supposed to be helping manufacturers to
build devices that don't do what they
say
and then it's um a bit of a i won't say
what he's saying over here
and he says he doesn't like products
that aren't carried in a store in
bellevue madrona digital
medrona digital as i explained my last
video is a custom integration company we
have high inclines of building a home
they come in and say look anything that
touches
basically
security lighting shades
distributed audio in a home and yes they
may have an avr and a bedroom that you
know plays stereo multi-channel music
occasionally we do a theater we're not a
retail company and
i praise incredible number of products
have nothing to do with my business
whatsoever when i praise the topping
deck i don't carry the topping deck
when i praise a molar deck a genelec
speaker a neumann speaker um you know it
just he makes no sense that the price
then on receivers i don't think we carry
or sell any of these things by the way
ironically a few years ago the rep for
ps audio when they before they cut the
legs from under all their reps and
dealers
and went direct
they came over and i remember going to
medrona and seeing one of these power
plants there with a pretty display and i
remember that display looked very cool
and then i asked how much cars and i was
like oh no
we can't carry it and they came back and
picked it up uh on this thing so
it has nothing to do with this kind of
innuendo do your homework if you want to
go after me personally paul
do some homework understand who we are
and what we are pick up the phone call i
draw digital and say hey do you sell top
index you know do you sell general like
speakers actually we do install some
generic speakers in some high-end
installs but you know it makes no sense
you know yes harman's
speakers perform well
i don't just say i like them i show you
the measurements that shows incredible
performance based on the best research
we know about how to make a
good speaker and i'm hoping they're
following harman research and producing
their speakers and if you don't agree
with me what do you you know agree with
what i mean this product with p12 was
sent to me i measured it
measurements say it does nothing useful
for anybody and by the way it degrades
performance based on undocumented issues
with this high car import uh you know
what do you want me to do i can't fake
the measurements i didn't go in there
and produce
bad measurements because i could uh he's
confused me with people who write
subjective reviews and
if you don't bother their brother the
right way they can say negative things
about you and who's to say otherwise oh
i listen to this amplifier it sounds
cold yep you're screwed and a bunch of
people are not going to buy that i am
because it sounds cool i don't have that
luxury i could buy measurements and the
instrument doesn't care what madrona
carries what material doesn't and uh
you know
you can go ahead and produce the same
measurements and show different results
the fact that you haven't done one
measurement like i performed
shows that you know
you either don't understand or don't
care about the truth and you just want
to
pass on some nonsense
and then he really disappoints me with
this next one he says my hope is that he
becomes a productive member of the
community rather than a thorn in his
side
which community the uh manufacturers
have built stuff that can be shown to do
anything good for a consumer yet cost
nearly six thousand dollars
i'm not ever going to be part of that
community i am providing a service for
customers of ps audio their customer had
a p12 sent it to me for testing their
customer had their tags sent it to me
for testing the customer had their amps
send it to me for testing i've tested
probably seven or eight products from
them one of them i like the rest of the
measurements show
really you know either okay or poor
performance with really bad ideas
audiophile mist that they've chased and
put in products without a single control
testing without proper measurements to
understand what they do they don't do so
paul your wish will never come through
uh you know i've been fortunate to have
had my long successful career and now
i'm spending my hobby time
measuring stuff from the community and
speaking to what they do i have no fear
of you saying i won't be part of your
club
um
you know
go ahead and challenge me on marriage
don't make up you know rumors and stuff
about what i like and don't like on this
thing and uh he says you know he wants
to straighten out the facts and products
are misrepresented in what way did i
misrepresent your product paul
i measured what he did to a power supply
i measured what it did to an amplifier
you haven't shown one measurement that
disputes any of that whatsoever there's
not one thing you had an opportunity you
put a camera in front of a designer
you could have tried to replicate my
test and show different results so why
didn't you do that well because you know
you can't produce different results or
you don't understand the measurements
still which by the way is part of my
suspicion or that you're not capable of
setting up those measurements you don't
have the right instrumentation when i
look at the bench from your designer
for sure i don't see any audio precision
in there i don't see a spectrum analyzer
i don't see a thd meter for mains
all i see is two volt meters to
200 400 devices and you're trying to say
you know you're measuring things you're
not measuring things those are just toy
measurements that were not in dispute so
i want to say you know as much as i look
passionate right now i do approach every
product without passion or prejudice you
know i just put the product on the bench
and i'm like you know you clean up ac
maybe cleans up i mean i had no
you know thought that it would reduce
power in an amplifier i i was shocked
when i hooked up the high current thing
i'm like whoa there's eight percent less
power you know what's going on in here
and we spent our own resources trying to
figure out how the device worked
after paul said oh he was mistaken about
how the device worked so
from that point of view
the thing i can promise him and
everybody industry is that you will get
your product
fairly evaluated 100 i cannot cook the
measurements i can't the game
can mistake happen sure you go ahead and
show me the mistake um there was a note
he put in there that i didn't use the
latest firmware i did use the latest
firmware at the time that the product
was in my hand on march 18th they
released another version of the firmware
no release notes no statement about what
is fixed and that's after i did my
measurement
why would he say something like this
that i didn't get the latest firmware i
mean it just makes no sense
that's a classic thing of you know
creating foot around these things so
i hope the person that really steps up
is
paul mcgill and the company is ps audio
there have ton of capabilities to build
great products they have the wherewithal
they have manufacturing they have
employees they have engineers uh this
p12 is not a simple device to design
it's a lot of complexity in a designing
high voltage amplifier like that it just
said you know he's pointed at the ship
in the wrong direction he says built
five versions of this power plant
because when i hook it up i think my
ears tells me that everything sounds
great and i got these five reviewers
saying the same thing and six owners say
the same thing
gosh for a second do a blind test
set up your demo room
with the box in there but not always
hooked up you walk in a dozen times
and you know show whether you tell
whether you think the thing is in in the
system or it isn't
and see if you get it 10 out of 12 times
right hey how much work is that if
you've done that you just put a camera
in there show it to us a lot of us would
shut up
was the minimum we go buy one of your
power plants and try to replicate what
you did
but you know when you didn't do that you
didn't measure the device
you know the onus is on you to do the
right thing and that's the opportunity
for him my opportunity is at hand
i'm fortunate not to have the knowledge
and equipment that i have i'm going to
keep measuring your your devices as
they're sent to me
no more sent to me you won't see me
around but they're his customers are
interested in how they perform and uh
you know that's where we are anyway this
video is getting very long i'll stop it
here
hopefully you
weren't as fed up with it as i have with
the topic and and want to move on to
something else okay
see you in a future video bye-bye